- There she is, look at
how tall Nina is now.
- I'm tall.
- Dessert's coming, dessert's coming soon.
I'm excited, I'm excited, I'm excited.
Whoa, that's a little close!
Now I'm scared.
(whoosh)
(salsa music)
(moped engine revs)
Alright, happy weekend everybody.
- Hello.
- Once a quarter I take the people
who are a part of my
Toronto Dance Salsa Team
and I take them out for a treat.
And last quarter we went, was it bowling?
- [Nina] No.
- No.
Yeah, bowling, we did bowling
and the meal at the restaurant.
That was good times.
And this year we were supposed
to go tubing, but it's--
- But then.
- What?
- But then it's 11 degrees outside.
- Nina won't let me finish this story.
Okay go, you tell the story.
- It's 11 degrees outside,
it's too warm to go tubing,
so we've decided to go
to this yummy restaurant.
- Nina's very excited.
- And, let's go.
- Oh, wow.
11 degrees for our
American friends watching,
I don't know what that is but
we'll flash it right
here, what 11 degrees--
In the middle of February, 11
degrees Celcius, it's crazy.
- I don't get to go,
I'm staying and playing
with Jeffrey and Stephanie.
- You're going to have
more fun there anyway.
Let's do it!
(upbeat music)
Alright, we're here, I made a mistake.
Last time I paid for everybody
to go on the boat cruise,
which was a lot of fun.
And the time before that was
the lunch and the bowling.
And so we're here, we switched
our plans from snow tubing
because it's a glorious
day, I'm in shorts.
And sandals, but that's been
my theme this winter anyway.
Shorts and sandals, you've
got to get used the the cold.
Embrace the cold, it makes you stronger.
So this place, we came to,
what a couple weeks ago?
- [Nina] Yeah.
- The food was decent,
the food was really good.
But...
The real reason to come
is these amazing desserts that they have.
Stacked toast with ice cream
and a whole bunch of yummy.
And there were four of us
and we couldn't finish it last time.
And so I'm expecting some amazing visuals
and for people to really
enjoy the time together.
Come together as family
and Nina set it all up so,
we appreciate and love her.
Let's do it.
(upbeat music)
We're the first ones here,
we got this big table.
Nina's excited.
As we wait for people
to come and fill it up,
let me show you the menu, let me show you.
So this is the regular food,
it's all good, ramen.
This is what we came for.
Look at that, look at that toast.
Yeah baby these things are huge.
Nina's going to leave super full.
100% happening.
- Yeah, have to wear baggy clothes.
- [Evan] She's going to leave,
"Oh I'm so full, I can't eat anything."
- Alex is here, Don is here,
long time no see buddy.
- [Evan] Monica's all ready,
she's already organized everything.
- See my little pads now?
I'm working so much and thinking so much,
I'm wearing out my sweaters.
So now I've got a little pad right here.
- [Evan] How about your shoulders?
- I'm planning, I'm planning.
- [Evan] You have pads
on your shoulders too.
- Shoulders?
- [Evan] Yeah.
- When I have a hard day and
I need to lean on someone,
I got the shoulder pads too, you know?
Sort of have to lean like
this sideways but whatever.
Listen, stop judging.
(upbeat music)
Here we go, so we're going
to introduce all the helpers
right now that have made
it here tonight, today.
- [Evan] Wait, I thought you
were doing this on Snapchat?
- Yes I am.
Evan is here recording
me, I'm recording Evan,
I'm here with all the helpers,
they're going to introduce
their name and their
favorite salsa move, yeah.
- Hello, my name's Katerina,
and I've been helping
since September 2011,
and my favorite move is the matrix move.
- Hi, my name is Stephan.
I have to say my favorite
salsa move is the Stephan,
I kind of made it up, so if
you want to see what it is,
ask me to dance on the dance floor.
(laughing)
- Hi my name is Felipe.
My favorite move is the Coca Cola.
- My name is Janice
and my favorite salsa
move is the Bowling Ball.
- Hello my name is Lily,
I like quadruple turns.
- [Evan] That's fancy.
- Hi, I'm Ashish.
My favorite move will be
same as Felipe's, Coca Cola.
- [Evan] Nice, love it.
- Hi my name is Ananth, I like
the oyster, also Coca Cola.
- Hi, my name is Monica.
I've been helping out
since the spring of 2016.
And I love to spin, so
the more spins the better.
- [Evan] Nice.
- So I'm Nina, I've been
helping for over six years,
I like to do Body Waves.
- [Even] Very nice.
(laughing)
- Hi, my name's Jessie, I've
been helping for the last year,
and my favorite move is
the Women's Backwards Dip,
with the Head Roll.
- No redoes, no, it's all
been already posted online.
- No, really?
- Snapchat!
My name is Alex, I've been an
instructor for the last year,
and my favorite move is the Body Wave.
I do it all the time.
I love it.
Even though Nina loves it too.
(quiet upbeat music)
- [Evan] Nina spilled on herself.
It's okay, we still love you Nina.
(laughing)
We still love you Nina.
- [Woman] What is that?
- [Evan] You don't want to
try it, it's not really good.
They look really--
Wow guys, they're all gone. (laughs)
(quiet upbeat music)
- [Evan] Alex is doing his thing.
Oh, nice, nice.
- Look at that.
- [Evan] That's some
preparation, dude, I'm uh--
- Thank you.
- [Evan] You're on camera. (laughs)
- Alright, gang!
So, our helper of the
semester, the way we choose it,
is the one that gets the most feedback,
the most love, and so,
we look at all the feedback--
It was over like 200 feedback
from different students,
on everybody.
I literally just counted the names,
I'm like, "Who stood out the most?".
So...
Fall,
2016,
Helper of the semester is,
Monica!
(cheering and applause)
You get your golden tag, that's one.
- [Nina] Awww.
- [Alex] You get your
one free class at TDS,
nine-week class.
- Aww, thanks.
- [Alex] Use that for anything you want.
So here's some of the
stuff that people wrote.
"Monica's a great
assistant, a great helper,
"Monica adds a lot of thought
"and gave good advice
with my dancing form.
"Very motivated and helpful,
"great at leading the class."
- Oh wow.
(cheering and applause)
- [Alex] Have a great semester.
- I'm really happy.
Thank you guys for the
opportunity to be here,
meeting all you people is so fantastic,
I love you guys so much,
I want to keep doing it and doing it,
I hope to grow even more
and I hope to help even more,
and anybody help me out to get better
and I'll help you all out, that'd be neat,
and I'm so proud to be part of the family.
This is amazing, it's great,
thank you so much. (laughs)
(cheering and applause)
- Dessert's coming, dessert's coming soon.
I'm excited, I'm excited, I'm excited.
Whoa, that's a little close!
Now I'm scared.
The plates are here.
Ohh!
- [All] Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Ananth,
- Thank you.
(cheering)
- [Evan] Blow it out!
(upbeat ragtime music)
Round two.
- Alex is dancing.
He's got strawberries inside him.
Strawberries! (laughs)
(upbeat ragtime music)
Okay, so there's a quote I
read recently that I love
and it just talks about
the spirit of really,
focusing on yourself and being happy.
When I think of you,
when I think of my family
and over the last eight years
since I became a student,
how...
How grateful I am,
and I would never have
imagined myself being here,
sitting with all of you, and...
My one word is belong,
I was always looking for a place
where people wouldn't judge me,
would make me feel like
I'm part of their family.
So the quote says, or the quote goes,
"Work like you don't need money,
"love like you've never been hurt,
"dance like nobody's watching."
And so, gang, whenever I'm
at the studio, I'm dancing,
I feel like nobody's
watching, nobody's judging,
and I hope you feel like that too.
All the love I receive from you,
it's like all the things in high school
and all the awkwardness
I've had in my life,
it doesn't happen,
and whenever I talk to you
I always feel that it's
a genuine relationship.
And I'm working at TDS because
I don't care about the money,
I don't care about the power,
I don't care about the attention.
I care because...
We're doing something bigger.
We're doing something bigger
for ourselves, and for others,
and every time I see any
of you talk to a student
or you're talking to each other,
and the light that lights up,
and the light that lights up in me,
it makes it a very special place.
And so, thank you so much,
for being part of my family.
Thank you for letting me be
part of your family, your lives,
and I just...
It's incredible, and I'm
super proud of all of you,
and just, what we have here.
So thank you guys.
(cheering and applause)
(laughing)
Real men cry, okay?
Real men cry, Nina.
- Alright, we're done.
I'm feeling full, how's Nina feeling?
- I'm ready for a nap.
- Just stand up here so you're taller.
There she is, look at
how tall Nina is now.
- I'm tall.
- So that was insanely filling,
good times though!
Amazing people, love the TDS family,
thank you to Nina for setting that up too,
organizing the tubing, and
then organizing this. (laughs)
And all the chaos that went with it.
You did a good job.
Mwah!
Hope you guys have an amazing weekend.
- [Both] Continue to believe!
- Whatever your one word
is, we will see you soon!
(laughing)
(woosh)